هربنا وجئنا إلى تركيا وما إلى ذلك.
أستطيع أن أقول إن آلامنا كبيرة وفي الوقت المناسب.
هنا أيضا
[موسيقى]
على سبيل المثال، بدلا من الجلوس هنا خاملا
دعني أذهب وأساعدك في العثور على شيء أفضل.
لذلك نحن نساعد ونوزع الطعام.
ثم ينتهي في مثل اثنين أو ثلاثة
ثم سنعود مرة أخرى في الساعة 6. العشاء مرة أخرى.
نحن نوزعها، إنه شعور جميل، هكذا هو الحال
جو لطيف مع الناس والأطفال
الشعور بمشاعر كهذه تجاههم
المساعدة شيء عظيم.
وفي النهاية هم سعداء
عندما نساعدهم وما إلى ذلك.
بعد كل شيء، نحن سعداء، ولهذا السبب أنا أيضا
أنا سعيد أن هناك زلزال أو شيء من هذا.
كان علينا أن نبقى بالخارج
لم نفهم البطانيات أو أي شيء على أي حال.
لقد تركنا في البرد لأننا كنا خائفين من البقاء في الداخل.
لذلك أستطيع أن أقول للجميع الشفاء العاجل.
رحمهم الله حقا
الألم عظيم ويستمر
تركيا
[موسيقى]